>> Greg: JOHN KERRY GIVES US A
SCOOP THAT SLEEPY JOE IS OUT OF
THE LOOP.
YES, HE DOES DAMAGE CONTROL IN
FRANCE WHILE BIDEN WANDERS
AROUND WITHOUT PANTS.
[LAUGHTER]
WALKING DRIFTWOOD SCULPTURE
JOHN KERRY SAYS PRESIDENT BIDEN
WASN'T AWARE THAT THE TRILATERAL
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE U.S., THE
U.K. AND AUSTRALIA WOULD ANGER
FRANCE COME BECAUSE IT WASN'T
FRENCH.
THE DEAL SUNK A $40 MILLION
SUBMARINE CONTRACT BETWEEN
FRANCE AND IN THE OFF-SEASON
FRANCE RECALLED ITS INVESTORS
UNITED STATES AND JOE BIDEN
RECALLED OUR AMBASSADOR TO
ATLANTIS.
JUST KIDDING, JOE CAN'T RECALL
ANYTHING.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ASKED ME
ABOUT IT AND I TOLD HIM, HE SAID
WHAT'S THE SITUATION THAT I
EXPLAINED EXACTLY, HE HAD NOT
BEEN AWARE OF THAT.
HE LITERALLY HAD NOT BEEN AWARE
OF WHAT HAD TRANSPIRED.
I DON'T WANT TO GO INTO THE
DETAILS OF IT.
>> Greg: WHY BOTHER AT THIS
POINT?
BEFORE HOPPING ON HIS PRIVATE
JET THAT RUNS ON PANDA BLOOD, HE
SAID THAT THE U.S. AND FRANCE
HAVE BIGGER WORLD ISSUES TO WORK
ON TOGETHER SUCH AS CYBER
WARFARE AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND IF THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
LOST INCOME, HE RECOMMENDS
MARRYING A RICH WIDOW SO YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO FLY ON PRIVATE JETS.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
BUT THEN THEY CONCLUDED THIS
INTERVIEW WITH THIS FASCINATING
NUGGET.
>> ASSURED, INTERNATIONAL
DIPLOMACY IS IMPORTANT AND YOU
KNOW I THINK CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
CRUCIAL ISSUE OF OUR LIFETIME.
BUT NOT AS CRUCIAL AS GREG
GUTFELD BECOMING THE KING OF
LATE NIGHT.
WHAT HE'S ACCOMPLISHED IN SUCH A
SHORT TIME IS AS CREDIBLE AND
BEAUTIFUL AS APPLE TOWER, DON'T
YOU THINK?
>> Greg: THEY THINK.
WHO KNEW HE WAS A SECRET FAN OF
THE SHOW?
BUT AS FOR BITE AND BEGAN AWARE
OF THE DEAL, THAT SEEMS ODD AT
THE VERY LEAST.
RIGHT JOE?
>> LOOK.
I AM ON TOP OF THINGS,
ALL RIGHT.
I KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
IT'S JUST THAT THE SUMMARY DEAL
WAS CONFUSING.
FIRST OF ALL, WHERE I COME FROM
WE CALL THEM HOAGIES, RIGHT?
SECOND OF ALL, YOU'VE GOT AU,
U.S., U.K., E.U.
THERE'S TOO MANY LETTERS.
I GAVE IT TO CARRY.
HE'S GOOD AT THE ALPHABET.
IT LOOKS LIKE A MUPPET.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IT RAISES THE
QUESTION, WHAT ELSE DOES JOE NOT
KNOW AND WHEN DID HE NOT KNOW
IT?
>> WELL POLITICIAN SAY THAT ALL
THE TIME.
I DIDN'T KNOW OR HE DIDN'T KNOW.
IN THIS CASE I BELIEVE IT.
BUT I ALSO DON'T KNOW IF THAT
INSPIRES CONFIDENCE.
IF WE ARE TRYING TO BE GETTING
ALONG BETTER WITH FRANCE, TO
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN US.
HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON.
WHY WOULD YOU BOTHER TO TALK TO
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON?
I'VE TRIED, DOESN'T WORK VERY
WELL.
>> Greg: IF YOU KNOW
PROFESSOR, DO YOU THINK
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY LIKE IT THIS
WAY, THE LESS JOE KNOWS, THE
BETTER.
>> IT'S HARD TO KNOW BUT WAS
JOHN KERRY THE OPERATIVE WORDS
WERE, I EXPLAINED LITERALLY,
UNAWARE.
HE'S ALWAYS THIS PONTIFICATE
ARE.
REMEMBER DURING THE ELECTION AND
HE SAID, IF YOU DON'T EDUCATE,
YOU ARE NOT EDUCATED AND GO TO
COLLEGE, WE WILL SEND YOU TO
IRAQ AS IF THAT WAS THE WORST OF
ALL FAITHS.
REMEMBER DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HE WAS ALWAYS
FREELANCING ON THE IRAN DEAL,
MEANING IRANIAN.
SO IT'S ALWAYS THAT HE IS THE
HERO AND INTELLECTUAL MASTER OF
EVERYBODY.
SO IT WAS PROBABLY TRUE THAT
BIDEN DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON BUT, HE ALWAYS EXAGGERATES
HIS OWN ROLE.
REMEMBER HE WENT OVER TO CHINA
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND THEY
PUT HIM IN A ROOM AND SAID TO
COME UP LATER.
SO HE'S ALWAYS A LEGEND IN HIS
OWN MIND.
>> Greg: TO BE FAIR, CHINA
THOUGHT HE WAS ACTUALLY A
CABINET.
[LAUGHTER]
ANOTHER GREAT EXAMPLE IS HIM
GOING TO FRANCE AFTER THE
TERRORIST ATTACK AND BRINGING
JAMES TAYLOR BECAUSE IT WAS HIS
WAY OF BEING A HERO, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: THEY WILL LOVE ME
BECAUSE I'M BRINGING JAMES
TAYLOR BECAUSE NO ONE HAS EVER
SAID THAT BEFORE.
DAVID, ARE YOU AWARE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN YOUR RAZOR COMPANY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE I AM RIGHT
NOW.
JOE BIDEN OBVIOUSLY IS CONFUSED.
THAT'S NOT NEWS.
WE'VE KNOWN THAT.
WHAT I FIND INTERESTING IS,
FRANCE, THE HOME OF THE PARIS
CLIMATE ACCORD, IS LIKE, WE NEED
TO SELL OUR DIESEL SUBS.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I PREFER THE FRENCH
SUBMARINES.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
ASHTRAYS IN THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
NO TORPEDOES, THEY JUST FIRE
BAGUETTES.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO, IT'S TRUE.
>> Greg: AND EVERYTHING IS
DONE IN THE FORM OF MINE.
>> MINE.
YES, IT'S SILENT.
PAINT HANDS ON THE THING THAT
GOES THROUGH THE WATER.
>> Greg: WE SHOULD PROBABLY
STOP THIS.
>> WE SHOULDN'T HAVE STARTED.
>> Greg: MERCEDES, DO YOU
THINK KERRY IS JUST STUPID OR
WAS TRYING TO THROW THE
PRESIDENT UNDER THE YACHT?
>> KERRY WANTS TO BE IN THE NEWS
AND WANTS TO BE RELEVANT AGAIN
SO MY THEORY IS, YOU MUST'VE
SAID IT, LET ME JUST THROW THE
PRESIDENT UNDER THE BUS.
BUT THEN, I CAME HERE AND I AM
THE SMARTEST IN THE ROOM.
BUT WHEN HE MENTIONED YOU WERE A
KING.
LET ME SAY IT IN SPANISH.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
[APPLAUS